hey what's up i'm justine welcome to ask
ij
this past weekend i went to pax if you'd
like to watch that vlog feel free to
click here this is on my other augustine
youtube channel so if you want to watch
that go for it if not let's jump right
into the questions that you guys asked
me they are right here on this phone
this phone that is not an iphone 5 which
brings me to a question where someone
asked me about the iphone 5. let me just
find it for a second not amitrol wants
to know if i'm excited about the iphone
5. last time the iphone 4s came out i
pre-ordered it online like you normally
would you receive a ups box in the mail
and when you open it up you expect the
phone to be in there to my not delight i
opened it up and there was absolutely
nothing in it do you know what was
supposed to be in it
my iphone 4s mythical says i was falling
up the stairs and running into the door
i don't know how i can be so clumsy
today i fell up the steps and yesterday
i ran into a doorknob and my arm is
still hurting so bad
that was a reenactment that hurts this
is hurting still hurting still hurting
it still hurts that guy you love is
asking what is the worst thing that you
ever cursed out loud so i don't usually
like to swear but when i'm playing video
games i'm another completely different
human being what are you doing
you're a full pot of poo
it's a human being that i'm not very
proud of i get a little rowdy caitlyn
wants me to do the dougie i need
somebody to teach me how first cloudfang
how was pax prime like i said feel free
to check out the vlog on my other
ijustine channel i had an amazing time i
got to see a bunch of my friends and of
course play a bunch of video games if
you are a video game fan and you've
never been to pax i definitely highly
recommend checking it out hello i'm
amanda what animal do you think that you
most resemble i'm not really sure i'm
just gonna make a face
if you'd like to let me know what type
of animal you think that i most resemble
feel free to leave a comment in the
comment section below abby is asking if
i've ever got some teeth pulled yes i
have and some of you have probably seen
that video did you watch your tooth they
already threw it away
hey it's catherine wants to know where
he justine is she's i don't know where
she is
i can't find my glasses you can't see me
i can't see you
thank you guys for watching this episode
of ask ij if you have any other
questions that you'd like to ask me feel
free to ask them in the youtube comments
below because in the next episode i'll
be taking all of my questions from
youtube check out this playlist here
which contains all of the videos from
veda vlog every day in august i've never
been able to vlog every day ever so i'm
really excited and last but not least
don't forget to subscribe so you'll know
when i post a new video i love you guys
i'll see you whenever i see you bye